The International Space Station,...
...an unparalleled laboratory for cutting-edge research...
...unachievable in Earth's gravity for the benefit of all humanity,...
...an observatory for Earth's evolving climate,...
...a beacon of international collaboration,...
...and our home until 2030.
As the station enters its third decade, it is busier than ever,...
...developing technology for human exploration missions to the Moon and Mars,...
...finding new ways to combat disease...
...and acting as a test bed for in-space manufacturing of advanced materials...
...and new medical products.
Humanity's future is an ever expanding team...
...of nations and companies enabling exploration together and for the benefit of all.
The International Space Station is a critical step on a great journey ahead,...
...to the Moon and beyond.